and finally new rule Republicans have to
tell us now that you've made facts
optional and change the status of truth
to unknowable what's next
hypocrisy used to be a thing is it still
take a look at Paul Ryan at the State of
the Union when President Trump suggested
we create jobs by investing in
infrastructure the time has come for a
new program of national rebuilding yes
an idea worth standing and applauding
for here's Ryan when Obama suggested the
exact same thing take the money we're no
longer spending at war
use half of it to pay down our debt and
use the rest to do some nation-building
right here at home
yes either Obama forgot to say Simon
Says
or clearly the term Republican
principles no longer has any meaning
since Trump got elected they have pulled
utter 180s on infrastructure free trade
reducing debt Family Values the
Constitution when Obama signed executive
orders it was proof we were being
governed by a lawless tyrant now Trump
does it and he proudly displays them
like he's The Price is Right girl
Trump tweeted 27 times about how Obama
played too much golf now he plays twice
as much suddenly the problem of
presidents playing golf too much
disappeared faster than a Russian
journalist and even when you say as I
often do oh come on
wouldn't you be furious of if Obama had
said you know the White House is a dump
or whatever ridiculous thing Trump said
that we melt they never admit it we'd be
cool with it we're consistent so I got
to thinking what if I could actually
show Republicans what it would look like
if Obama had some said some of the
things the Trump has said so here to
help us with this little experiment
please welcome on his birthday today the
44th President of the United States
Barack Obama ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
go
thank you
[Applause]
all right so it's not the real Obama who
could afford his speaking fee this is of
course our friend Reggie Brown and he's
here to help Republicans is there to
help Republicans test their theory that
they'd be cool with it
and some of the crap that's come out of
Trump's mouth was said by Obama and I
stressed this may not be the real Obama
but these are really Trump's words every
one of them verbatim so let's begin with
one we all know what would it look like
if Obama had said this about John McCain
he's not a war hero he's a war hero
because he was captured
I like people who weren't captured not
only would he have not won the election
but the screen would have gone black and
when we came back Wayne Brady would have
been there one of the big Republican
complaints about Obama was that he
didn't respect the military enough what
if they had asked him how he came by his
military strategy and he said I'm
speaking with myself number one because
I have a very good brain and and I've
said a lot of things
I have a very good brain that was
another complaint about Obama always too
full of himself too full of himself what
if Obama had said sorry losers and
haters but my IQ is one of the highest
and you all know it what if he instead I
could stand in the middle of Fifth
Avenue and shoot somebody and I wouldn't
lose voters headline in the New York
Post black man threatened shooting spree
gunned down by police and no matter how
much scripture Obama cited Republicans
never believed he was really Christian
imagine if Obama had said why do I have
to repent or ask for forgiveness if I'm
not making mistakes when I drink my
little wine and have my little cracker I
guess that's a form of asking for
forgiveness
[Music]
my little cracker you mean you mean Jeff
fish another one of Obama's unforgivable
flaws was that he didn't find America
exceptional enough okay so if Bill
O'Reilly had asked Obama about Putin
being a murderer it would have been okay
if his answer was there are a lot of
killers we have a lot of killers do you
think our country is so innocent yes
Sean Sean Hannity's reaction would have
been now no politician ever tells the
whole truth always but what if Obama was
so blatant as to say I got to know Putin
very well because we were both on 60
minutes and then a few months later said
I never met Putin I don't know who Putin
is
yeah who you gonna believe me or me I
would not just sheer dumbness Obama
wasn't the most experienced president
ever but what would have been the
reaction if he kept claiming that things
everybody knows were just being
discovered
nobody knew healthcare was so
complicated we have to prime the pump
have you heard that expression before I
came up with it a few days ago and I
thought it was good Frederick Douglass
is an example of somebody who's done an
amazing job and is getting recognized
more and more
and we haven't even gotten to the Access
Hollywood tape Republicans you're really
going to tell me you would be okay if
Obama had said I moved on our like a
[ __ ] I just start kissing them
I don't even wait and when you're a star
they let you do it you can do anything
grab them by the [ __ ] grabbed by the
[ __ ] they blew a gasket when he said
cling to your Bible and you're going to
tell me you would be okay if our first
black president used debate time to brag
about the size of his dick he referred
to my hands if they're small something
else must be small I guarantee you
there's no problem I guarantee you
[Applause]
[ __ ] I don't know the exact definition
of white privilege but being able to
talk about grabbing [ __ ] and how big
your dick is and still getting elected
president that's got to come close